who got you into directing what was that
what was the thing that that kind of
just where it took off
um
well i mean i guess i i shot a short
film um
called twin turbo
twin turbo yeah it was a fun thing uh
and and then that got me
into the warner brothers directing
program uh and then after that i was
able to and then i shadowed
uh james bamford
and uh and our producing director kevin
mock um and then i directed for one of
the episodes of legends of tomorrow
what what's what's it like directing
the first time you directed on set for
legends of tomorrow was the first one
yeah first episode because you've
directed a couple right
uh i've done three legends in one flash
jeez
has anyone else in the cast done any or
done more than you um
more no but uh maisie who used to be on
the show she's not anymore she's
directed and then just mcallen as well
as directed
do you have any other actors
i think that was it
how did you feel like the first time i
said were you nervous be honest oh i was
so nervous
it's it's it was quite terrifying um
just because you're not sure what
is
fully expected you or what you know how
to
how everything works um i think the most
nerve-wracking part was always
when it came to blocking
because you're like okay and then
everyone's just you know and you're like
having to communicate with everyone at
the same time you're the director all
eyes are on you what are we doing yeah
and you're trying to explain to the
actors like and hoping to try to if you
have some idea that you you want them to
do and
um so you're especially on legends
there's so many people and
you know i like to design a lot of like
camera movement things i got it okay
all right you said
uh and it just it kind of requires maybe
specific movement from the actors and
the camera and uh
it's kind of like like a dance and and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and um it's just all eyes on you
and
everybody has all all the questions and
you know you're supposed to know all the
answers and
it's have you ever missed smallville
[Music]
no really i mean it was a big part of my
life our life
okay i mean you ever feel like watching
an old episode and talking about stuff
you know
no no
never well would you would you do it for
me
no would you do it for the fans
[Music]
yeah why not
be fun
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast do you ever say i
don't know oh what do you think about
you you do you you don't have your ego
you put your ego you leave your ego at
the front door i think in the beginning
i was more
uh
i
didn't want to say i don't know because
i didn't
want to people think i don't know what
i'm
yeah i just felt like as the director it
is my obligation to know and like so i
should know um
because it's my responsibility and right
now way more often like especially
notice this time on flash you know with
there was a question it it would be and
i didn't know i would be like i don't
know help me figure this one out or what
do you think um
and i think that's also really helpful
with with actors too if you say like you
need something or you don't know how to
something's not working but you're not
sure how to fix it and to just be like
i'm not sure how to make this work like
can you help me figure out this and
everybody then is
also
kind of then gets to shine a bit too so
people
can offer something that maybe you
weren't thinking of